mofas fahren in der atmosphäre der venus
den beweis für außerirdisches leben
bereits im vergangenen jahr hatten
astronomie teams im spektrum der venus
atmosphäre spuren des moleküls
aufgespürt das auf der erde lediglich
durch mikroben oder auf industriellem
wege entstehen kann
ein echter sensationsfund also und 40
jahre alte daten stützen und ist die
venus also doch rapid abel also könnte
dort ausleben existieren klicks um
science and future hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocke nur so verpasste nichts los
geht's angst nicht willkommen leben auf
der venus möglich oder nicht
im herbst des vergangenen jahres 2020
hatte ein astronomie team den
sensationsfund gemeldet mit hilfe von
radioteleskopen in chile und dabei
hatten die fachleute in der venus
atmosphäre einen super spektakulären
fund gemacht denn dort konnten sie mono
for fun nachweisen wie sie damals im
fachmagazin nature astronomie schrieben
das spektakuläre daran auf nicht
biologischem weg kann dieses molekül
wohl nicht entstehen fest steht auf der
erde kann es nur relativ kompliziert
künstlich hergestellt werden die einzige
quelle sind mikroben also die einzige
natürliche quelle die ganz ohne
sauerstoff auskommen eine heiße spur
also bei unserer bislang vergeblichen
suche nach außerirdischem leben die
studie erntete damals viel widerspruch
und skepsis in der fachwelt anfang
diesen jahres wurde eine studie
veröffentlicht in der andere
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die spektren untersucht hatten und keine
spuren des moleküls ausfindig machen
kann ein anderes forschungsteam gab an
dass die erste spur nicht auf mono
phosphat seien auf ein anderes gleis
hinweise dass auf der venus der oft
vorkommt schwefeldioxid stadt mono fonds
fahren war der angebliche sensationsfund
also gar keine entdeckung und jetzt gibt
es eine unerwartete unterstützung und
die kontroverse um potenzielles leben
auf der venus wird neu entfacht denn ein
nasa forschungsteam hat sich jetzt 40
jahre alte daten noch einmal genauer
angeschaut 1978 war
die nasa-sonde pionier - multi- probt
durch die atmosphäre der venus geflogen
und hatte dabei viele spannende daten
sammeln können auch spuren des mono
fonds fans waren damals dabei schreibt
das forschungsteam jetzt nach einer
ausgiebigen analyse der längst
archivierten daten und diese erkenntnis
ist wirklich nicht ohne denn dabei
handelt es sich um die erste unabhängige
bestätigung des sensationsfundes von
2020 und nicht nur das es wurden auch
weitere hinweise auf biologisch
relevante chemikalien auf der venus
entdeckt bei mono verfahren handelt es
sich um ein molekül das aus drei atom
wasserstoff und einem atom phosphor
besteht das besondere daran dieses gas
kommt auf der erde nur als
stoffwechselprodukt winzige bakterien
vor beispielsweise wird es von
mikroorganismen produziert die im kot
von pinguinen existieren auf der erde
wird diese substanz außerdem auch von
menschen künstlich hergestellt das ist
aber extrem aufwändig klar ist
jedenfalls dass phosphor atom in dieser
verbindung ist extrem reaktiv und genau
das ist der grund dafür warum dieses
molekül normalerweise schnell wieder
verschwindet die große frage also warum
befindet es sich in der atmosphäre der
venus und wie kommt es vor allem dorthin
astronomen astronomen kennen bislang
keine geologischen oder chemischen
mechanismen bei dem die verbindung auf
der venus immer wieder neu entstehen
würde bedeutet das etwa dass in einer
höhe von 50 bis 70 kilometern über der
venus oberfläche mikroorganismen
existieren und für diesen stoff
verantwortlich sind möglicherweise
handelt es sich um lebensformen die sehr
an bärtierchen erinnern diese könnten
sich in den verschiedenen schichten der
atmosphäre hin und herbewegen in den
unteren sehr heißen schichten würde
diese spezies dehydrieren und in eine
art starre verfallen in den oberen
schichten dagegen könnten sie dann
wieder erwachen die oberfläche der venus
ist jedenfalls derzeit eine echte höllen
landschaft hier herrscht eine
durchschnittstemperatur von rund 460
grad celsius sodass es heißt genug wäre
um leid zu schmelzen
die atmosphäre des planeten besteht zum
größten teil aus kohlendioxid und ist
zudem extrem dicht zu herrscht auf der
venus eindruck der auf der erde und
900 meter unter wasser zu finden ist
allerdings frühere studien zur venus hat
man's tageslicht gebracht das die venus
in ihrer früheren vergangenheit durchaus
bewohnbar gewesen sein könnte bedeckt
mit ozean und somit mit einer deutlich
kühleren oberfläche als heute ein planet
also auf dem leben einst sehr gut
vorstellbar wäre demnach könnte der
planet tatsächlich eine ganze zeit lang
äusserst lebensfreundliche
umweltbedingungen geboten haben die
venus soll in diesem stadium sogar der
erde ziemlich ähnlich gewesen sein auch
diese studie aus dem jahr 2009 10 hatte
bereits deutlich gemacht dass die venus
bei der suche nach außerirdischem leben
eine bedeutende rolle spielen könnte
als die forschung bis dann gedacht hatte
denn falls die venus mit großen
lebensfreundlichen ozean vielleicht
sogar drei milliarden jahre lang
tatsächlich wie die erde aus gesehen hat
ist auch eine sache ganz klar die
evolution hat die hier genug zeit in
aktion zu treten also es hätte sich
leben bilden können genügend zeit dafür
war da uns leicht haben sogar besonders
hartnäckige organismen bis heute
überleben können dazu der us astronom
dhabi da ja warum investieren wir so
viel zeit in die suche nach leben auf
dem mars wenn es dort nur 400 millionen
jahre lang flüssiges wasser gab
und dann steht dagegen die venus mit
drei milliarden jahren wasser und
niemand interessiert sich für sie nicht
auszuschließen also dass die venus sogar
der erste bewohnbare planet im
sonnensystem war
doch nicht nur das möglicherweise
befindet sich auch heute noch leben in
ihre atmosphäre die aktuelle studie von
rakesh module und seinem team der
california state polytechnic university
liefert dazu jedenfalls neue hinweise
die forschenden hatten sich alte bereits
archivierte daten noch einmal genauer
angesehen
diese waren von der nasa-sonde pioneer
windows multipoint 78 im rahmen des
programms der nasa gesammelt worden
die sonde war damals zur venus geflogen
und dort mit drei tochter sondern
kontrolliert abgestürzt unter anderem
das instrument large pro blüte mass
spectrometer ams hatten eine menge daten
in einer höhe von 50 kilometern über der
venus oberfläche gesammelt und genau die
haben die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler
nun genauer ins visier genommen und nun
steht fest auch damals bei diesen
kontrollierten absturz der sonde konnte
das gas mono fonds fan in der venus
atmosphäre nachgewiesen werden und nicht
nur das das forschungsteam hat in den
alten daten weitere spannende indizien
für die existenz von leben festgestellt
mit dabei unter anderem nitrat
schwefelwasserstoff kohlenmonoxid
ammoniak getan und nitrit komponenten
die unter anderem für den sogenannten
stickstoffkreislauf bedeutsam sind
vereinfacht gesagt wird bei diesem
prozess gasförmiger stickstoff in
wasserlösliche stickstoffverbindung
umgewandelt diese können dann von
pflanzen und lebewesen aufgenommen
werden findet in der venus atmosphäre
möglicherweise sogar so etwas wie
photosynthese statt
das aufgespürte nitrit wird zumindest
auf der erde von bestimmten bakterien
für die sogenannte antigene
photosynthese genutzt im gegensatz zur
oxygen photosynthese wird dabei kein
molekularer sauerstoff erzeugt sondern
andere anorganische stoffe wie etwa
elementarer schwefel
klar ist jedenfalls die photosynthese
auf der erde ist eine biochemische
reaktion die das leben hier erst möglich
macht und auf der venus dazu schreibt
das forschungsteam wenn wir die
potenzielle bewohnbarkeit der venus
wolken betrachten zeigen unsere arbeiten
eine mögliche signatur des analogen
vostro stoffwechsel sowie wichtige
chemische beiträge so an ob sie gehen
photosynthese und zum terrestrischen
stickstoffkreislauf was am ende
tatsächlich für den mono phosphatgehalt
in der venus atmosphäre sorgt kann mit
letzter sicherheit nur durch eine
mission zur venus herausgefunden werden
ganz vorne mit dabei ist das so genannte
da vinci plus programm der nasa
hier könnte sich ein roboter sondern auf
den weg zur venus machen und dort die
atmosphäre des planeten untersuchen dazu
sagt der nasa forscher david grüns tun
wenn man den ergebnissen der studien
nachgehen will dann ist da vinci die
logische wahl denn man muss einfach
dorthin reisen und sehen was in der
atmosphäre vor sich geht konkret könnte
sich die da vinci sonde durch die
atmosphäre der venus bewegen und dabei
verschiedene messungen vornehmen
wie ist die atmosphäre zusammengesetzt
sie ist sie entstanden und welche
chemischen prozesse laufen dort ab und
warum
neben den messungen könnte die roboter
sondern aber auch bilder von der
planetenoberfläche liefern klar ist
bisher nur einen endgültigen beweis für
leben dort oben haben wir immer noch
nicht doch vulkane mit owen witze oder
sonnenlicht sind schon einmal nicht die
erklärung für die beständige neubildung
dieser verbindung dafür ist die
gesamtmenge der substanz in der venus
atmosphäre
nach angaben der fachleute viel zu groß
an den riesigen gas planeten saturn und
jupiter wurde in der vergangenheit
übrigens auch schon mofas fahren
nachgewiesen doch hier sind die
gigantischen energiemengen im inneren
dieser himmelskörper die erklärung dafür
bei der venus ist das aber nicht der
fall ausgeschlossen ist es somit also
noch lange nicht dass wir es hier mit
dieser entdeckung endlich geschafft
haben außerirdisches leben auf die spur
zu kommen leben auf der venus
wissenschaft findet für sensationsfund
nur eine erklärung also hier gibt es
alles über die ursprünglichen entdeckung
draufklicken anschauen wir bleiben dran
am thema bleibt uns treu und abonniert
klicks um den podcast bis dann bleibt
dran